un stade bien garni pour une affiche
historique 2000 supporteurs ont fait le
déplacement pour voir ce 32e de finale
de coupe de france entre versailles et
granville les versets qui évolue en
nationale 3 n'avait plus atteint ce
stade de la compétition depuis 2011
c'est comme un 32e de finale puis un ami
à moi qui joue monsieur oussama berkak
le chercheur salue aujourd'hui j'espère
qu'il va marquer malgré leurs divisions
d'écart les versets qui marque en
premier sur penalty mais se font
rejoindre quelques minutes plus tard le
score à la mi temps un partout je pense
que techniquement les deux équipes se
valent mais ça va jouer à très serré je
pense granville marquera un second but
en seconde période malgré quelques
actions en fin de match et les
encouragements de leurs supporters
versailles ne reviendra pas et se fait
sortir de la coupe de france sur le
score de 2 1 ils vont être un peu plus
d'expérience que nous là sur ce mot sur
ce genre de match qui sont quand même
important donc j'ai tiré un peu plus
d'expérience après je pense pas qu'on
avait quelque chose à leur envier qu'il
soit techniquement ou physiquement
une ou deux erreurs défensives mans qui
nous ont coûté des buts on a été punis
froidement mais voilà c'est la vérité du
32e de finale de coupe de france de ce
niveau là et là dessus il faut il faut
apprendre
du côté des supporters les sentiments
sont partagés on est quand même content
de la prestation des joueurs
là on aurait pu gagner les faire
beaucoup mieux mais c'est pas grave on a
vécu quand même un bon match quand on
regarde le contenu ça laisse ça laisse
des regrets parce que c'est dommage
voilà maintenant il ya des faits de jeu
et perdre contre lui mais je pense
qu'ils vont gagner championnat de n3 ce
sera la consommation des stars et les
versets y sont à l'heure actuelle
premiers du championnat de nationale 3
avec un point d'avancé sur leur dauphin
ivry pour se remettre de cette défaite
en coupe il faudra l'emporter ce samedi
11 janvier à domicile contre l'équipe 2
du paris saint germain